when we were off camera we talked about
kyle rittenhouse sure right
and then uh you and tyler i think what
comment did you make about kyle
yesterday on tucker you said he's a good
kid he's a he's a kid that you would
find in your typical suburban chicago
neighborhood yeah and and tyler what did
you say you said something about the guy
he came off as a good kid you know he
worked hard he worked as a janitor to
support his family he was a lifeguard he
was a medic and he was just completely
lamb bad it's like he's a completely
different kid than what the media sure
and then we talk about blm and you know
how he supports blm but he says i don't
support the writing or i don't know
the writing i just support the movement
though sure i support a movement great
fantastic and then the conversation was
what well he was coached sure because he
was coached to do something like this
right and then another interview on the
tucker he was coach which by the way do
we all agree that he was coached one
million percent of his coach there's no
question he wasn't coaching of course he
was coaching
but
no matter how much he coaches me
how long will it take you to coach me
to beat you in mma if we go and grapple
how long i don't know you're looking in
pretty good shape and i know you're back
what i'm trying to say to you is what
i'm trying it's going to take more than
a day or two it's going to take probably
a few years right because that's been
your world
no matter how much he coaches me or your
friend coaches me how much is it going
to take me for me to go do a stand-up
comedy and get a 60-minute special how
long is it going to take me 5-10 years
it's going to take a while right so so
no matter how much you press this power
versus force concept to people they're
not gonna it's not gonna be a day or two
or it took me three five years to fully
understand what i was dealing with with
this i know you i know you want to move
on but i have one question on that
because i i understand that on an
individual level and it's a really great
way to be introspective and see where
you're at
now on a collective level
we just saw for 20 months here fear is
is an incredibly powerful tool for
control you get people to feel afraid if
you can control their media's business
model yep yeah i mean they're three c's
right baby change conflict controversy
they made people afraid of the air man
there's people still right now i was
just in st louis there's people afraid
of the air yeah walking around outside
muzzled up yeah like yep like
if you could control them where they see
every human being that they encounter as
a potential threat
you you can do anything you want with
those people now now you're the savior
hey yep this is scary world
give me come with me yeah i'll help you
i'll save you it's just going to cost
you all your money and your freedom yeah
but i'll protect you i'm the good guy
right i got the jab all right
whatever whatever whatever you need
maybe
but fear
the the lowest level of that
force versus power
just
put the world on pause for two years
they took the whole world over for two
years by making people afraid okay so
how do you how do you process that from
an individual level to a collective
level yeah first of all the fear
sharpens listening right when people are
afraid people listen so they have to
scare the hell out of you for you to
watch the news if they don't scare the
hell out of you they're not going to
watch the news so
you you got to figure out a way to
increase the identity of people and like
for example running the company when we
started off the company a php insurance
company the first thing i said is saving
america by bringing back the free
enterprise system and hope to american
families right there's two things you
can train people on willpower skills
skill is how to sell will is you can do
it right
typically most people think it's skill
set that's very necessary willpower is
just as necessary matter of fact
slightly more necessary than skill
because willpower may will make you
figure out a way to learn the skill
you're going to figure out the skill
right okay so yes
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]